PROFESSOR: So what are
we going to do today?
So, today we're going to
continue with amino acids,
peptides, and proteins.
And I want to talk about
a different protein
variant that is the causative,
the cause of sickle cell
anemia.
And it's a very interesting
structural issue.
But let me very briefly
recap what we did last time
and then talk to
you a little bit
about a process known
as denaturation.
So last time, we discussed
how the primary sequence
of a polypeptide chain
defines its folded structure.
The folded structure
is put in place
with secondary and
tertiary interactions,
non-covalent interactions.
Secondary just amongst
backbone and its tertiary sort
of everything else, even
including backbone amides,
but either with water, or
a side chain, and so on.
And then there are some
proteins that dissociate
into quaternary structure.
So these monomer subunits,
as they would be called--
and I'm going to depict this
as a closed circle or an open
circle--
may form dimers of some kind.
The dimers may be heterodimers.
Or they may be homodimers.
Or you could form trimers,
tetramers, and so on.
And when we talk
about hemoglobin,
which is the protein that
gets, that has a problem--
that is the cause of
sickle cell anemia,
you'll see that that is a
heterotetrameric protein.
So in this sort
of rendition, you
would kind of draw it like this
where there are four subunits.
Two are of one flavor
and two are of the other.
And that's the quaternary
structure of hemoglobin.
Now proteins fold.
There are weak forces that
are holding them together.
But there's a lot
of weak forces.
But if you subject a protein
to various treatments that
may break up those weak
forces, the protein
will undergo a process
of denaturation.
So can anyone think of
what kinds of things
would cause protein
DNA denaturation?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some heat.
PROFESSOR: Heat is a bad one,
is a serious one, obviously.
And heat-- yes, I'll
write them all down.
What's yours?
AUDIENCE: pH.
PROFESSOR: pH.
So pH.
Acidity.
Basicity.
And we'll talk about why
those things cause changes.
Any other thoughts?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yeah.
So for example, salt.
Organic solvents.
And a process that
a lot of people
don't necessarily think about,
but as engineers some of you
will, is shear forces.
So if you're shooting a protein
through a very narrow tubing
and there's high shear
forces, those who will also
denature nature proteins.
So with heat, it's very clear.
You're going to break
those weak bonds.
And then they can either reform.
Or if you go to too high
heat, the unfolded protein
starts to form aggregates.
And anyone who has
ever scrambled an egg
knows that that is an
irreversible process.
You don't get to cram the
egg back into the shell.
It's not the same anymore.
Because what you're doing
when you're scrambling
eggs is denaturing proteins
through heat treatment.
So that's what heat does.
It breaks the forces.
The proteins stretch out
into their denatured state.
And instead of refolding
to a compact structure,
they just start aggregating
with each other.
And that's pretty
much irreversible.
pH is interesting.
Why would pH break up
at low temperature?
Why would pH cause changes?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] amino
acids have a certain structure.
So they're either protonated
or deprotonated, then the pH,
that would change.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So pH, perfect.
So pH will change
the charge states
of many of your sight chains.
And once you've
changed it, you might
have had a lovely
electrostatic interaction.
But then you go and protonate
the carboxylic acid.
And it can't form-- in
fact, it wants the form,
it wants to break apart as
opposed to come together.
So that is changing
charged state,
which causes denaturation.
Salts and organics.
For example, they
may make interactions
with parts of the protein.
For example, organics,
organic molecules
may slip into a hydrophobic
core and break them up.
Just push them apart.
They want to be there.
And then too much of
a high concentration
of an organic solvent that
is miserable with water.
And we would say ethanol,
acetonitrile, DMSO.
But you don't need
to worry about too
much of which details.
Well actually, once you
get above 10% or so,
we'll just start denaturing
proteins, sometimes reversibly
but often irreversibly.
So this is very important to
know that proteins are stable,
but you've got to
treat them nicely.
There are some
human diseases that
are a result of misfolded
or aggregated proteins.
So for example, all
the prion diseases
are proteins gone
bad, pretty much,
where they are not in a
folded structure anymore,
but they are in aggregates
that cause problems
with cellular
processes and toxicity.
So Alzheimer's disease.
Mad cow disease.
A lot of those are
neurologic disorders
caused by poorly folded or
very misfolded proteins,
for example.
So these are the things
we talked about last time
with respect to the flux
from primary to secondary,
to tertiary to quaternary.
And that's a perfect time
for me to introduce to you
what we'll talk about today.
So last time we talked
about structural proteins.
And I showed you
how collagen, just
with a simple defect, changing
a glycine an alanine in one
of its subunits, really alters
the quaternary structure
of the protein to make
very weak collagen
that's no longer supportive
of bone strength.
But what I'm going to
talk to you about today
is a defect in a
transport protein
that carries oxygen
around the body.
So we're going to
talk about hemoglobin.
These diseases
are what are known
as inborn errors of
metabolism, or that's
kind of a complex term.
Or genetically linked
diseases, because there
is a single defect
in a DNA strand
that then gets transcribed
into an RNA strand.
So one base defect that then
becomes an amino acid defect
in your protein strand.
So these are tiny changes
in the protein that
cause dramatic changes
in the structure
and function of the protein.
And what you will
see with hemoglobin
is it causes a real problem
with the quaternary structure
and causes proteins
to aggregate.
So hemoglobin is the dominant
protein in red blood cells.
Or erythrocytes.
And in fact, the differentiation
of the red blood cell
as it comes from
progenitor cells
goes through a process where
the red blood cell dumps out
its nucleus so it
can't divide anymore.
And basically, the
content of the cell
is extremely high in hemoglobin.
You've packed the hemoglobin
into the red blood
cell at the cost of
losing the nucleus.
So that's terminally
differentiated.
Can't become a red blood cell.
It can't divide anymore.
And it has about
a half-life, they
have about a
half-life of 100 days.
So they turn over,
and then that's it.
And when red blood
cells turn over,
the hemoglobin has to be
taken care of in order
that it's not toxic.
Red blood cells are red because
of a particular molecule
that's in the hemoglobin
called the heme molecule, which
is bound to iron, which
provides the hemoglobin
with the capacity to pick
up oxygen in your lungs,
travel it around the
body, and then leave it
where it's needed.
And then replace
the oxygen with CO2
and take the CO2 back
to the lungs in order
for you to respire it out.
OK?
So hemoglobin carries
oxygen and CO2,
from oxygen from the lungs,
CO2 back to the lungs.
And the reason why
you need the iron
is that the iron is
coordinated to the oxygen.
So the heme molecule--
I won't draw it.
If you want to see it, it's a
big, complex organic structure.
Very interesting structure.
But something for
another day here.
But I want to just stress
to you that the iron heme
complex is red.
That's why your
blood cells are red.
Your blood cells
don't have a nucleus
so they can cram in
lots more hemoglobin.
So it's kind of a
fascinating situation.
So hemoglobin is an example
of a homotetrameric protein.
And it has four subunits.
Two of one flavor
and two of another.
So we call this an
alpha 2 beta 2 protein,
differentiating the alpha
subunits and the beta ones.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't
it homotetrameric?
PROFESSOR: Why isn't
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You
could ask why is it?
I don't know.
I mean, there will
be interactions
amongst the subunits that favor
that particular packaging.
The subunits are kind
of similar in shape.
They have what's
called a globin fold.
You can more or less pick
out those tubes, remember,
alpha helices.
They could form tetramers
that are all the same,
but the energetically favored
form is the two and two.
Hemoglobin is a
tetrameric protein,
because that's really
advantageous for picking up
oxygen and dropping off oxygen
in a very narrow oxygen range.
So there are proteins
called globins
that just one of these
that can bind oxygen.
Hemoglobin is tetrameric
because it has
a cooperative oxygen binding.
So in a very narrow
range of oxygen,
it fills all four sites
in the tetrameric protein
with an oxygen Molecule.
So it's very advantageous
from a physics perspective
that it responds to
very narrow changes
in oxygen. Does that
make sense to everyone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
It means, anything that's
cooperative means that one,
let's say I've got a
tetramer of hemoglobin.
One oxygen binds to one of them.
So I'm a binding oxygen here.
And then binding to the
next, the next, and the next
gets easier and easier.
So they sort of want
to come in as a team.
And that's handy for
maximizing oxygen transport
around the body in a narrow
oxygen range, which we can only
deal with what's out
there in the atmosphere,
so we have to make this work.
Does that answer your question?
OK.
All right.
So where was I?
OK.
So what we're going to do today.
We're going to
look at hemoglobin.
It's the tetramer.
Those discoid structures are
the hemes that I just mentioned.
I've drawn them as this
sort of four-leafed clover
here just for simplicity.
And there is a single
defect in the sequence
of the single monomer
subunits in hemoglobin.
So each of these--
let's go here.
So there are four
proteins-- beta globin,
two copies of beta globin, and
two copies of alpha globin.
They are all-- let me see.
What's the size?
Do, do, do, do.
[INAUDIBLE] You know,
I can never see things
when I'm up at the screen.
But they're about 150.
156.
OK.
So they're about 146 amino
acids long in each of them.
And a single defect
in the beta globin
where you have a change
from glutamic acid
residue 6 to valine
at residues 6--
one change in beta
globin, which means
two changes in the
whole structure,
because there are
two beta globins--
alters the properties of
the hemoglobin and causes
what's called sickling
of your red blood cells.
So let's take a look
at what that would look
like at the amino acid level.
Glutamic acid is one of
your charged amino acids.
I'm just going to draw
a little bit of it
as it were in a peptide.
And it's at position
6 in the sequence.
So it's six residues
from the amino terminus
because we always write
things in this direction.
And the change takes place
to put in place a valine.
And there's a pretty big change
in identity and personality
of those residues.
You've gone from polar charged,
to neutral, big, fluffy,
hydrophobic residue.
And it's really amazing.
So the beta globin is
expressed on chromosome 11.
It's 134 million base pairs.
One base has changed.
So what you have in the
DNA, in the normal DNA that
encodes the normal
beta globin gene,
there's a particular
sequence of nucleic acids.
This is what the double
strand would look like.
We're going to see way more
about nucleic acids next week.
When that gets converted
to the messenger RNA,
you get a particular code
that in the genetic code
codes for glutamate acids.
Everything's normal.
A single change, if we change
the center nucleic acid
within the DNA, it makes
a different messenger RNA.
And one base pair puts in valine
instead of glutamic acid out
of 134 million base pairs.
So what happens in
the normal hemoglobin,
you have normal behavior.
You had this
tetrameric structure.
It cooperatively
carries oxygen. It moves
around the blood no problem.
Excuse me, it sits
in the erythrocytes
or red blood cells no problem.
The minute you
have that mutation,
the hemoglobin molecules
start to associate
into clusters like
fibrillar clusters,
because each tetramer gets
glued to another tetramer,
and another one,
and another one.
So you have hemoglobin
not behaving
as this beautiful, independent
quaternary structure,
but rather sticking
to, physically
sticking to other Molecules
And those tangles
get, those molecules
get so large that
they start to form
long and inflexible chains.
And it's such a dramatic change
that that discoid structure
that you're familiar
with for red blood cells
suddenly becomes a sickle shape.
So that would be the normal
cell with normal hemoglobin.
But sickle cell,
they look like this.
They're kind of curved,
odd, a very odd shape.
And the problem
is red blood cells
have evolved to
move really smoothly
through your capillaries.
As soon as you get a
different shape that's
sort of not that
discoid structure,
they start clogging
in the capillaries.
And when you have the defect
where all of your hemoglobin
is messed up with
this variation,
it's incredibly painful, because
think of all your capillaries
going out to the farther
reaches of your joints.
Those very thin blood
vessels are blocked up
with the sickle red blood
cells that are caused
by the variation in hemoglobin.
So that one little defect
takes us all the way
to a serious disease.
All right?
So what I want to
do very briefly
is show you the
molecular basis for this.
All right.
And the defect actually appears
on the two beta globin chains,
but right on the
outside of the protein,
not in the middle
of the protein.
Because this is a defect that
affects how proteins interact
with other proteins,
not the function
of the protein on its own.
Probably still carries
oxygen just fine.
But it's the mechanical
change in the hemoglobin
that causes the disease.
OK.
So sickle cell
anemia, the hemoglobin
is now called hemoglobin
S with that mutation
that I just described.
And when people
are heterozygous,
it means they have one good
copy of the gene that's normal
and the copy of the
gene that's the variant.
And you'll learn much more
about this in human genetics
when we talk about
that later on.
So you have a mixture of the OK
hemoglobin and the sickle cell
hemoglobin.
People who are homozygous
for the defect, all
of their hemoglobin
is disrupted,
and those are the
people who really end up
in hospital with a lot of
transfusions, and so on.
The heterozygous, actually,
you can manage quite well with.
And I'm going to show
you in a minute that
in some parts of the
world, being heterozygous--
i.e., having some of your
hemoglobin with a defect
and some without it--
actually confers an advantage.
It's a really cool story.
So what I'm going to
do is quickly show you
the wire structure.
OK, so this is the structure
that elucidated the real reason
for the interaction.
What happens when you
have this mutation.
And it was a structure
that was captured
of a dimer of
hemoglobin molecules
where you could really
see what was happening
at the interface and the sorts
of changes that had been put
in place by that
variation from the charged
to the neutral structure.
So for any of you
who want to pop by,
I can start to show you
how to manipulate PyMOL.
We can do that
separately from class.
But this is a
dimer of tetramers.
And if I just show you
just some of the subunits,
I can actually show
you how there's
two of each subunit
in each structure.
So if I, go I can pick some out.
Every other one.
And then I can color
them a different color.
You can see where the globins,
where the beta globin are
and where the alpha globins are.
That's still looks
like chicken wire.
It's very unsatisfactory.
So what I can do is I can show
you everything as a cartoon
and get rid of all
those little lines.
And then you can see
perfectly the structure
where you see two beta
globins and two alpha globins
in each structure.
OK?
So what we're going
to do next is zoom in
to see what's
happening where we've
done this mutation, what's
going on with the placement
of the valine in that structure.
All right?
And wherever I put a four-letter
code-- so that one was 2HBS--
that's what's known as the
protein data bank code,
and it enables you to
go fetch the coordinates
of that protein.
So if any of you
for the late project
want to do a protein structure
and print it, come to me
and I'll explain a
lot more about that.
Or the TAs can also do that.
So let me now move you
to looking in closely
to the variations.
So what I've done here is
I've actually colored--
the beta globin is purple,
and the alpha globin
is cyan colored.
You can see the hemes
in each of the subunits.
Those are those red wire things.
And now we've zoomed
into the place where
the mutation is where
you have a valine instead
of carboxylic acid.
And what you can see from
this image which should stop
is that the valine on one
subunit in one homotetramer
interacts with a sticky patch
on another subunit that's
made up of phenylalanine
85 in the adjacent protein
and leucine 88 in
the adjacent protein.
So this sticky patch
on one surface glues
onto a sticky patch on the
surface of another tetramer.
If you had glutamic glutamate
there, would that form?
No.
In fact, it would be quite
deterred from forming
because you don't want to cram
that negatively charged element
into those two
hydrophobic residues.
So what you've gone from is
a situation where this really
is fine on the surface.
It's hydrated.
It's not sticking to anything.
To another situation where you
have phenylalanine and leucine,
which are both hydrophobic,
providing a patch on the one
tetramer where the valine from
the other tetramer combined.
And because the
molecule's a tetramer,
on each of the
subunits, there is also
another valine that will go
off and do that elsewhere,
and another valine.
And there's one you can't
see that's tucked behind.
So that's why the hemoglobin
forms these structures,
because every
hemoglobin molecule has
two places to stick to another
hemoglobin tetramer, and so on.
So think of the repercussions
from one nucleic acid change
that's really quite remarkable.
So what we've seen here is
that that change occurs.
And just a couple of moments
for you to think about this,
you can have variations
at that site that
won't cause a problem.
Which ones of these
do you think are
least likely to cause a sickle
cell type of phenomenon?
So tyrosine, serine,
aspartic acid, and lysine?
So I'm going to change the
glutamate to something else.
Which one's going to have a
perfectly normal hemoglobin?
There's one that stands out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Aspartic.
That's fine.
No problem.
It just switched it for
its younger brother.
Well, which one of the others?
And in many cases here,
you could probably
argue your way to all of them.
But one would be pretty bad.
Which one would be pretty bad?
Tyrosine, exactly.
It's another.
Even though it's
got that OH group,
it's still pretty
hydrophobic because
of that ring system there.
What about the other
two, serine and lysine?
What do you think?
Which one would probably be,
in fact, the least detrimental
of those remaining two?
And give me the reason as well.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Lysine.
PROFESSOR: Lysine.
I think it would be lysine
because lysine is now
positively charged.
It's equally unlikely to want
to do this goofy interaction
because it is also charged, just
charged in the other direction.
But one could also argue
that serine would be OK
because it's a little
bit more polar, so it
wouldn't cause as much problem.
OK.
Finally, this issue
with sickle cell anemia,
there's some
fascinating data that
shows in parts of the world--
for example, during a drug trial
for plasmodium falciparum, one
of the causative
agents of malaria,
they found that 1 out of 15
people with the sickle cell
trait was infected with malaria,
whereas then the people who
were healthy, normal homozygotes
for the right hemoglobin,
14 out of 15 were infected
with plasmodium falciparum.
Now why do you think that is?
How can we relate the
infectivity of a parasite
with the shape of a cell?
We've gone from these
juicy-looking red blood
cells, nice and round
and probably quite open,
to a cell that's sort
of difficult to shape.
So it turns out
that the parasite
doesn't want to infect
the sickle cell red blood
cells anywhere near as well.
And there are, for example,
other bloods tested which
shows the same correlation.
And here's a map of Africa
where you see a massive overlap
of the prevalence of
the sickle cell trait
and the presence of
plasmodium falciparum.
So there is an
evolutionary advantage
to having the
heterozygous variant
where you have some
normal hemoglobin but some
of the sickling hemoglobin,
because it confers
you some resistance to malaria.
It's not good to
have both of them,
the variant that
causes sickling,
because that's
painful and it really
causes a lot of
health disorders.
It's just when you have
one of each gene encoding
both variants.
OK?
All right.
Great.
OK.
So now we're going to
talk about enzymes.
And these are the proteins
that catalyze reactions.
Any questions about that?
So while a lot of
disease states actually
might be bred out
because someone
would be at a disadvantage
with a particular disease,
in this case, that trait
has been maintained
because it offers a
very different advantage
with respect to disease.
OK.
Let's talk about
enzymes for a moment.
Or for the rest of
the class, in fact.
OK.
So enzymes are the heavy
lifters of the protein world
because they catalyze all
the reactions in metabolism,
in biosynthesis, all
kinds of transformations
that make you want you are.
Enzyme is a
protein-based catalyst.
You all know that.
Terrible writing again.
There were a couple
of other times
I just quickly want to give you.
So an enzyme, there is also
a term known as an isozyme.
And an allozyme.
You may see them.
You'll see allozyme
less commonly,
but you'll see isozyme
quite commonly.
An isozyme of one
enzyme is a variation
on the enzyme that
catalyzes the same reaction,
but it's expressed
on a different gene.
An allozyme is the same enzyme,
but with a variation in it.
So it's encoded by an
allele of one gene.
So it's just a variation
of the gene that might have
happened through a mutation.
Still catalyzes the reaction,
but there's a slight change
in the sequence.
But they're coded
by the same gene.
Same gene, with a variation.
And as I said, you will see
the isozyme term more commonly
than the allozyme term.
Now why do we need enzymes?
Well, the problem is there
are physiologic reactions
that we need to carry
out that are just
too hard to carry out at room
temperature pH 7 in water.
They just don't occur.
So you need enzyme
catalysis for all
of your metabolic reactions.
Let me just give you
one trivial example.
This bond you already
know nicely now.
Peptide or amide bond.
If I want to
hydrolyze that, if I
want to break it open, pH 7,
physiologic temperature, so
37c, in water, it
would take me--
how many years is it?
The half-life of that
bond would be 600 years.
OK?
That's pretty untenable
for digesting a Big
Mac even that even under
the best of circumstances.
So we need enzymes to speed
up breaking down proteins
and carrying out reactions
because otherwise,
we just can't-- we
can't do anything.
So what I want to
describe to you
are some of the details
of how enzymes work
and then how we can control
the function of enzymes.
So typical enzymes take
a substrate to a product.
Some enzymes may
take two substrates
and make one product.
Some enzymes maybe
take one substrate
and make two products.
It just depends on
the transformation
that you're doing.
Enzymes are classified into a
bunch of different families.
But the thing that will
tell you that something
you're reading
about is an enzyme
is the suffix ASE at the end
of the name of the enzyme.
So the enzyme that
hydrolyzes the peptide bond
or hydrolyzes
proteins is called,
no big surprise, a protease.
And you'll see later
on ribonuclease, DNAs,
oxidoreductases, all
kinds of reactions
where if you see this term
at the end of the name
it's telling you quite loud
and clear that it's an enzyme.
Just a very sort of simple
way of remembering that.
Now enzymes promote
reactions in order
that we can have them carried
out at room temperature.
But we want to think about how
they carry out these changes
and transformations.
What is it about the
structure of the protein that
enables these reactions?
But the first
thing we have to do
is take a look at the
thermodynamics and kinetics
of a transformation.
So before I go anywhere,
what I want to do
is describe to you
how enzymes work
by thinking about the
physical parameters
that we describe the
energetics of a transformation.
So in thermodynamics,
you all know
delta G is delta
H minus T delta S.
And we're really only going to
worry about one of these terms.
We're going to worry about
delta G, and I'll explain why.
So delta G is the
Gibbs free energy.
H is the enthalpy T is
the temperature in Kelvin.
And then S is entropy.
So these are the two terms when
you're looking at an energy
diagram, we generally
think about reactions where
we describe the y-coordinate
as the change in delta G,
the change in the free energy,
and the x-coordinate is
your reaction coordinate.
So in going from a
substrate to a product,
we generally have
a situation where
we have a substrate
at a certain energy,
and then maybe a product
at a different energy.
And we're going to talk
about the details of that.
So why do we deal with Gibbs
free energy, not enthalpy?
Does anyone know?
OK.
Enthalpy describes the energies
of all the bonds in a molecule.
But when you're doing
an enzyme-catalyzed
transformation, you're
not busting open
all of those bonds.
You're not breaking something
down to carbon, hydrogen,
and oxygen. You're only dealing
with parts of the energetics
of the molecule.
You're only dealing with
what's known as the free energy
changes.
So looking at the
enthalpy changes
isn't going to get you very far.
It's not going to
describe the reaction
because the enthalpy
changes would be enormous
breaking down that molecule.
And that's not what
you want to achieve.
In a chemical transformation,
we care about delta G.
Now the next thing
to think about is
what are the energetics
of the reaction,
and how does an enzyme-catalyzed
reaction manipulate
those energetics?
So the key thing here
is we want to talk
about Gibbs free energy.
I shouldn't have written
quite this much stuff here
because I need the Blackboard.
All right.
So when you describe
a reaction, you
want to understand how
far that reaction goes
and how fast that reaction goes.
So when you go
through a reaction,
we can describe how
far the reaction goes
by thinking about the free
energy of the substrates
and the products.
So in this case, the substrate
is at a higher energy
than the products.
So you will go a long
way through the reaction
to make quite a lot of
products in a transformation.
So that describes how
far the reaction goes.
So that is the difference
between the energy
of the substrate
and the product.
How fast the reaction goes is
described in a different part
of this diagram.
Does anyone know what it is?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Activation rate.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
How fast the reaction
goes is literally
how high the
mountain is that you
have to get over to carry
out the transformation.
And that height is described
as the energy of activation.
So that tells you how fast,
and the difference here
tells you how far.
The energy of activation is
a really important parameter
because it's actually what gets
manipulated when you're dealing
with catalyzed reactions.
So the energy of activation--
the higher that mountain
is, the slower the reaction
will be because it's a
much harder transformation
to go through.
The reactions in our bodies
can be of different flavors
depending on the
difference in energy
of the substrate
and the product.
So shown there, substrate
going to product
where the product is at lower
energy than the substrate,
we would call this
an exergonic reaction
because we're releasing
energy in the transformation.
So S higher than P. Exergonic.
And if we have a
different reaction--
and I'll sketch
this one in here--
where the product
is higher energy--
and this is a
reaction coordinate--
then that will be an
endergonic reaction.
Both reactions happen in
enzyme-catalyzed systems.
And we'll explain why
you're able to catalyze
even ones that require energy.
So exergonic releases energy.
And endergonic requires.
OK.
What else have I got on here?
We also, in the situations
where energy is produced,
the exergonic reactions, we
call these catabolic processes.
And if you have
trouble remembering
catabolic and anabolic,
just join me in
that because I always
forget which is which.
But the ones that produce
energy are catabolic.
The ones that require
energy are anabolic.
And when we think
about metabolism,
the catabolic reactions are when
we're breaking molecules down
because we need energy.
We need to use it
to do something.
The anabolic reactions are
when we want to store things.
Store fats, build
proteins, because they're
going to be endergonic.
They're going to be requiring
energy to take place.
I just forgot one thing
that I have shamefully done.
Remember, this axis is
kilocalories per mole
most commonly when we're
talking about delta G,
or kilojoules per mole if
you're in a different part
of the world.
But it's important to have
units on these diagrams.
So that tells us
a little bit about
enzyme-catalyzed reactions.
We need the enzyme
to do something
about this energy of activation.
Because if we didn't have
a high energy of activation
and I brought a Snickers
bar to eat during class,
I would just burst
into flames, right?
It needs a high
energy of activation
to keep it stable under
regular conditions,
but only break down
the bonds at times when
you require that breakdown.
All right.
So what did the catalyst do?
OK.
Now I'll show you
the simple reaction.
The enzymes are a
very large structure.
It binds to a substrate,
chemistry happens,
and it releases a product.
But at the same time, you
can't disobey the principles
of thermodynamics.
So there are certain
criteria we have
to think about when we consider
an enzyme-catalyzed reaction.
So first of all, do not disobey
whichever law of thermodynamics
it is.
They do not change
delta G. Delta
G is a property of
the two reactants.
You're not going to
change it with a catalyst.
It's going to have a much
more, a more important impact
on a different parameter.
Which parameter do enzymes
change and help lower?
Over there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So catalysts do
change and in fact
lower energy of activation.
And we'll talk about how
they do that the end.
And then the last
rule about a catalyst
is you can recover them
unchanged after a reaction.
It would be a lousy catalyst
if it did its chemistry
and then you've used
up the catalyst.
So enzyme catalysis are the
ultimate green reagents.
You can keep using
them thousands
and thousands of times
to continuously turnover
transformation.
So you haven't
changed a catalyst.
So the things that we want
to think about is how--
what are the processes that
enzymes can manipulate?
And I should probably
just quickly run
through these slides so we've
talked about these entities.
But I put them on the
board because they're
particularly important.
So the energy of activation
of a catalyzed reaction
is lower than the uncatalyzed.
And I'm not going to bore
you with these questions
because you can work
this out quite readily.
So delta G is the free
energy that changes.
And these are endergonic because
the energy of the products
is lower.
So this is the slide I
want to get to with respect
to the enzyme--
to enzyme catalysis.
So we always think,
well, gosh, the enzyme
is really large relative
to the size of the product.
That's because all the energy
within the protein-folded
structure is very
useful for lowering
the energy of activation
of a transformation.
So let's say I have
a reaction that
involves two substrates coming
together to make a product.
If I'm off the
enzyme, these guys,
it's going to take them a long
time to bump into each other
to do chemistry.
The way enzymes catalyze
those types of reactions
is they have binding sites
for both of those compounds.
In fact, the enzyme
acts as a stage.
One substrate binds.
The other substrate binds.
They're binding close to
each other on the enzyme.
Chemistry can happen.
It favors reactions that
involve multiple molecules.
What about another situation
where you have a bond--
for example, the amide bond--
the proteases break?
It's hard to think of how that--
how can we make that more easy?
Well, amides are
most stable when
they are flat and planar through
this arrangement of atoms.
But what can happen
on the enzyme
is that they can twist bonds to
make them less stable and then
more easy to hydrolyze.
So the structure of that
enzyme basically holds
onto the substrate and
twists or distorts the bond
that you're trying
to do chemistry on
to once again lower the
energy of activation.
Another way enzymes work
is in a reaction where
you're breaking
this bond, you might
make charged intermediates.
The enzyme's there to hold
those charged intermediates
in order to stabilize them.
Once again, to lower
energy of activation.
So it's funny when you get
the question that's well,
how do enzymes
catalyze reactions?
There is no one rule.
You want to think
about the reactions
and then just think about the
ways in which an enzyme could
contribute to that.
For example, orienting
two substrates
ready to do chemistry.
Causing physical strain in a
bond that you want to break.
Or comforting electric charges
that form during a reaction
coordinate.
So there are loads and loads
of different principles,
and it's a really important
study that is carried out.
So finally, I think
I have a couple--
oh no, I have a
couple of minutes.
But I want to just
describe this to you.
It'll also be covered
in the sections,
because I'm going to rush it
a bit because this last bit
features a little
bit on the P set.
So finally, enzymes are very
commonly the targets of drugs.
We like to think that some
drugs are important targets.
If we deactivate the
enzyme, we might mitigate
the symptoms of a disease.
Now you can't go in
and heat the enzyme
or denature the enzyme if
you're trying to treat a person.
So we do a lot of work
to mitigate disease
by inhibiting enzymes
with small molecules.
So in these slides,
I describe to you
the types of molecules that
may alter the chemistry
of a transformation.
So if a substrate binds
to an enzyme-active side--
we often do this
Pac-Man rendition--
you could design a molecule
that binds there instead
and basically inhibits the
substrate from getting there.
This would be called a simple
reversible inhibitor that's
competitive with
the active site.
There are other inhibitors
that will bind to the enzyme
but do chemistry with it and
stay blocked at the enzyme.
And that would be called
an irreversible competitive
inhibitor.
You can't get the inhibitor off.
And there's differences in
the way you can reverse this.
Because for example, up here,
if I add a lot more substrate
and these are equilibria,
I can get my reaction
to happen any way.
But here, I could add as
much substrate as possible
but it won't help.
It won't reverse
the transformation.
OK?
And there's a question here
to restore the reaction.
The answer really
is, you just have
to start with a new enzyme
cause you covalently
changed the protein structure.
The last type of inhibitors
that are important
are the ones that bind at
different sites on the enzymes.
And they are called allosteric.
Allo always means different.
So if you have a compound
that's an allosteric inhibitor,
it might bind on another
face of the enzyme,
but it will alter the active
side so it doesn't work.
That's an allosteric inhibitor.
And the final type of compound
is an allosteric activator
that may bind somewhere
else on the enzyme
but make it more active.
So these are the way
small molecules work.
I'd like to encourage
the TAs to just cover
this in a little bit more
detail because I've rushed It.
And I'll also re-mention
it at the beginning
of the next class.
But bear in mind, we should
have everything covered now
so the problem set 1.
And if you have any
questions, reach out to us.
Covered them in section.
And I'll reiterate a little
bit of this in the next class.
And finally, there's a
little bit of reading.
If you would like
to prepare, we'll
talk about
carbohydrates next time,
one of my favorite molecules.
And there's also a fabulous set
of videos on how enzymes work
at the Protein Data Bank site.
And you will see
this little handout
on the version of the
slides that's posted.